T
SIGNIFICANT UICKLY TGH THAT
THANK YS,.>>> JOININ JONATHAN
WHAT ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT NOW D
>> WELL, I'MED ABORE GOI
MILLIONSAT. WITLEVARIANT, 2NTRAB
SPAN TE BETWN
WAITING TH
ANPING TL T'S NOT STED
SPITALATY WOOUIS HOSPITAL STAFHN
ZATION
PLACES, RISE
ICANTLY, YOUI .C., A
MEAPE SEEING HOSPITALIZAS
IT A GOING TDENDWHENTHISGE CRES
VACCINATEDHA AND D.C., THEY'RINI
WANES E URALCTION.S THIS MEAN RE
LI SOMEONEE
BEING NATURE'S VACCINE.. YOU'VE
WH SAY WA.
FLA HAD
THAT'S-FCR ICASE0%REASE INHOMUNR
FOR THISIASO, IFSTYING
GOIT INFECTED AND
TWO A VACCIN SIO
STILL LILYO GEL.A BOOSR INCREASH
C INFE  75%.
ILLNS OD AIN
FOELY, ONLY ABOUT
ONE-THIRD OFN THISY WHO HA BN VA
FULL IF YOHI SHOT.
S FSON  SECOND
THAT FUL TWO N'
>>U THINK THE SNU' FIRST
PERS T THAT.
>>L, LF OLEYING THISWE D
WHLI.ORRIED
ABOUT UNDERMINING FOIDENCE IN TA
THOUPEOPLE
KNA
THREE-SHOTAC
IF YOUAVR THIR
SHOT, YOU'RE NOT ED, PEOP W
UNU STILTHAT
IT PORTRAYS THIS NOTIOTH
THIRS OP, YOU
KNOW, IT EXT
TAKE T OION.
ACPT AF TH
IF YOUK OUS A WHOLE, ONLY ABOU%H
FAORIN HAVNOT BEACUNPREPARED
OMICRON.
OUE STRED
CASO, EVERYONEDS A THIRD
INIF YOU'RE ON YOU
AS YOUECTION AGAINSTN, YOU'RENAO
FLORIDA
E GPOPULATION IN TH
VACCINATED AND GET
STOP THEE PEOPLE TVOTED FO>> A
E A RESTAURANT
WIOU N
WTIES
WOENGAGE INOW? I
DRININI WOULDN'T GO ONI WOULDN'
AROUND T T WEARING A MEDICAL
GRADE
TOLERATE THAT FOR A PERIOD O
TH PANDEC. THEEGINNINGF CE
NDWHENHE ACAOW
R YBE PUBLIC WL T INS WHERSPALPR
ND MAYBE LOCKDOWD PLTOHOMEOR A
EKU WE GET
BETTER CTRTHBUT THNO
OF LIVNOW BECAE TIRED OF THIS AN